the important job of educating the
country's more than 50 million public
school students Falls to just over 3
million teachers only on CBS this
morning we are very proud to announce
the 2017 National Teacher of the Year
drumroll please she is Sydney Chaffee
Sydney Chaffee chaffing JP it's a fee
right Sydney Chaffee okay we'll call you
by your right name Sydney's the ninth
grade humanities teacher at Codman
Academy in Dorchester Massachusetts we
asked some of her students why they
think she's so great good focused in the
room good use of resources five more
minutes on this and we'll go over it
Sydney is different in the way she
teaches it's a very blunt calm and nice
at the same time she motivates you to
like do your best and she push you
basically she found ways to get in my
head of the words you have left what
would make sense that she really cares
about us it takes the time to get to
know us she's a good listener like if
you ever have trouble or you ever need
to talk
she's one that you could talk to we were
but she can relate to us she's like a
tall adult white lady talking to like a
bunch of wipe it by kids
yeah ambiguous means unclear so if it's
difficult to define it's unclear right
she asked questions to make sure that
you understand exactly what she said you
have a quick question
super quick question she'll ask
questions that makes you want to ask
questions this one has to do with the
legacy of colonialism wants a legacy
just amazing person in the classroom and
out the classroom they're probably a lot
of other great teachers but so he's just
the best
very good
very good is right Sidney Chaffee
welcome and congratulations you tall
adult white lady no no I love that they
said that about you but also that they
call you by your first name yeah well
that's doing that we do it at our school
it's it's policy at the school we call
kids by their first names they call us
by our first names we want to just sort
of show that we're on the same level and
it's it's a community and we have
relationships and what do you think is
your magic in the classroom because I've
heard you point out yes I'm a white
teacher teaching kids of color but you
said that there's there's something in
that the way the message that you want
them to get yeah I mean I want my
students to understand that that they
are powerful and that they can make
change in the world that whatever
whatever the future is that they want to
see they have the power and they have
the agency to make that happen and so
that's that's at the core of everything
that we're doing so what are those
lessons entail so we learn a lot about
history and the history of people who
have been oppressed and the history of
people who have been marginalized and
how those people have fought for justice
so we learn about resistance movements
and then we sort of relate that to today
and say ok so what can we learn from
this and how will you be a powerful
person in the world do you think great
teachers have some instinctive quality
that they are born with or learn early
or is it something they're taught no I
think you know I'm a teacher so I think
everyone can learn and so I think that
there there is some sort of special
magic but but we always special mention
I don't know what it is but I think that
there's this deep desire to to make
change and to build relationships with
kids and that's really magical and if we
have that at the heart of what we're
doing we're going to do good work but we
can always get better so this you know
this award is so humbling because I
always I'm thinking about how I can be
better at this job and I know that all
of my colleagues are always thinking
that too and so that's another part of
the magic is just that teachers
understand that we're learners we're
always learners and we model that for
our kids
tell us about your school my school is
amazing I love it I've been there for 10
years it's a tiny little school in
Dorchester in Boston we have in the high
school we have about 145 kids total Khan
Academy I'm gonna go to murder school
yeah we are we're a public charter
school down in Dorchester when and why
did you decide you wanted to be a
teacher I didn't realize that I wanted
to be up
poet and I went to college to be a poet
and I had amazing teachers and they sort
of made me realize yeah they made me
realize oh this this is work that I
could do and so I sort of started on the
path late in college and went from there
and looking back I can see that there
were all these signs that I was supposed
to be a teacher you know I was always I
was a little bit of a know-it-all but
but yeah it all sort of came together
following your lead Sydney thank you of
the year thank you so much